right now
the fence against omicron is to get
vaccinated omicron i should say is to
get vaccinated and to get boosted
if you're boosted your immune response
will be stronger so yesterday in
addition to offering a second dose to
all 12 to 15 year olds the independent
jcvi recommended that boosters should
now be offered to everyone over 18
and that we halve the minimum gap
between a second dose and a booster from
six months to three months that means
that over 14 million more adults have
now become eligible for a booster in
england alone so i'm here today with the
health secretary sergeant javid and
amanda pritchard chief executive of nhs
england to set out our plan to make this
happen
the target that we've set ourselves
is to offer a booster to everyone
eligible
by the end of january
and as with the first jabs we'll be
working through people by age group
going down in five-year bans because
it's vital that the older and the more
clinically vulnerable get that added
protection first so
even if you've had your second job over
three months ago and you're now eligible
please don't try and book until the nhs
says it's your turn
we've already done almost 18 million
boosters across the uk
but we've got millions more to do to
protect the most vulnerable
then we'll move down the cohorts rapidly
and working together with the devolved
administrations we want to ramp up
capacity across the whole united kingdom
to the levels we achieved in the
previous vaccination effort
we're going to be throwing everything at
it in order to ensure that everyone
eligible is offered that booster in as i
say just over two months
across england we'll have more than
fifteen hundred community pharmacy sites
vaccinating people near
where you live
all of our sites will increase their
capacity and will stand up extra
hospital hubs on top of those already
active
there'll be temporary vaccination
centers popping up like christmas trees
and will deploy at least 400 military
personnel to assist the efforts of our
nhs alongside of course the fantastic
jabs army of volunteers
i know the
frustration that we all feel with this
omicron variant the sense of uh of
exhaustion that we could be going
through all this all over again but
today i want to stress this
today that's that's the wrong thing to
feel because today our position is and
always will be immeasurably better than
it was a year ago what we're doing is
taking some proportionate precautionary
measures while our scientists crack the
omicron code and
while we get the added protection of
those boosters into the arms of those
who need the most so we're going to get
behind the men and women of our nhs
who've saved so many lives on the front
line and run our vaccination program for
a year almost without a break as they
have and who are going back into the
breach yet again
and
i want to say on behalf of the
entire country a thank you to each and
every one of them for their
extraordinary efforts
and the best way we can all show our
gratitude
is by doing our bit and stepping forward
when our time comes to get that booster
i've been waiting uh patiently for for
my moment to come and it's happening on
thursday i'm pleased to say uh so
whenever your turn comes get your
booster and ask your friends and your
family to do the same
it's time for another great british
vaccination effort we've done it before
and we're going to do it again and let's
not give this virus a second chance